channing one of my biggest
disappointments of the last few years is
that the 21 jump street men in black
crossover did not happen oh reach into
the car and we're right there with you
preaching to the choir i i still i still
think it can work i i really do and if
and if sony would ever really like
i think you know do the hard work and
figure out the producer sort of uh like
problems and you know that are inherent
with that film i think we can still do
it but uh you know right now right now
it's it's still i don't know why i don't
know why they're just not motivated to
do it it's a big overhead on that movie
so but it's by far and away the best
third sequel to any franchise that i've
ever read in my entire life funniest
script
or none of these scripts are none i
would not say that if if i didn't really
really believe it because i don't like
being wrong yeah uh like specifically
about that i act i i have so many other
questions but i think what i think the
hold up is probably that all the people
in men in black have to have their
contracts renegotiated for the producing
deals to make this all happen am i wrong
on this or is it is it one of these
no there's spielberg uh
neil moritz and uh god who's the who's
the other walter walter walter parks and
like they're big two big franchises yeah
they have giant uh producers you know on
that and then once everybody's kind of
like not willing to come off their feet
you you end up having a producer fee
that's essentially maybe more than the
actual budget of the movie so it's uh
it's it's healthy
i i need i'm [ __ ] angry about this
anyway let's move on to dog um
so uh i know listen this is your
directorial debut for both of you what
was it about did you come close to
directing something else or was it
always
in the last few years were you just
looking at this
no we got really on the one yard line we
were doing all kind of uh actual prep
and and real creative uh steps for
gambit uh and we man i worked on the
movie for almost four or five years and
then read for about two and a half um
and we went through
i went through three different directors
on the movie but they ended up coming
off and on for lots of different reasons
for studio stuff for their stuff my
stuff and then
we kind of took them took the script
away and and worked on it really hard
fell in love with it and we were like
look i don't think anybody knows this
script like we do and
that didn't unfortunately happen because
it got sucked up in the acquisition of
fox by disney and marvel and uh and so
now we had to kind of start at scratch
and we we found a little little dog
movie that we fell in love with yeah
still hold out a little hope that gambit
comes to life at some point but yeah
light a candle for it
uh definitely um you guys you listen you
thank a lot of people in the credits but
i want to ask you
three people you specifically thanked
were alan horn seth rogan and soderbergh
what were those why did you thank those
three people
um well alan is yeah
uh yeah alan's my father-in-law and and
he gave some really great notes and
suggestions during the
development process of the film and just
was so generous with his time and input
so um i mean i've you know showed him
the movie really early i mean just like
it was just a really nice person to have
in our corner creatively um and seth
rogen helped us with with navigating and
uh well dga yeah oh no we one would be
really clear on this uh we're thinking
seth rogen that that he he truly went
above and beyond trying to help us with
the guild and then soderbergh is an
obvious one um he's you know he's been a
he's been a creative
sort of compatriot for a really really
long time and and we we owe a lot of
what anything that we know about
storytelling to him one of the things in
i'm going to bring in john wick 3 to
this and hopefully this will make sense
uh hallie trained for like a year on
john wick three so she would be the dog
trainer on set where the dogs would
really respond to her and i'm curious i
read that you trained for months uh so
were you essentially the dog trainer
on set with lulu or the three dogs or
were there also how did that actually
work
yeah so it was really complex actually
so we
hallie and and john wick she is
controlling all the dogs like you know
and they all listen to her she's like
the mother um in our movie the dog's not
supposed to listen to me like and so we
i had to really do this really
delicate walk where i can i had to bond
with them enough that i didn't get like
bit in the face when i'm yelling at them
and like a
like a small car
uh and then also
bond with them enough that they that i
can get them to do the things that i
need them to do kind of subtly but they
all had their own trainers very
specifically um that ended up adopting
adopting them actually um so yeah it was
kind of a bit of a two-hander you know i
i would i would work my certain things
that i needed to do with them but uh
really the trainers were they were like
magicians with these dogs
i love talking about the editing process
because that's where it all comes
together so when you guys first got in
the editing room were you ready to jump
through the window or were you like oh
we have it
i i'm always ready to jump through yeah
yeah i'm at ready at all times at all
times to jump through any windows most
most days uh but i gotta say i almost
did no editing on this movie because i i
tried in the very early days but editing
myself is not something that's healthy
for me
i can tell you that like i'm just like
oh yeah that scene's got to go that
scene's gotta go yep definitely that
scene and they're like we know
we want
we don't have a movie if you keep
cutting scenes and i was like yeah this
is not healthy for my brain my mental
health uh so i just was like you got
this yeah yeah like look i mean we had
it's always crazy when you look at the
first cut of a film that you put a lot
of time into you're usually
wanting to kind of like run out of the
room screaming and vomiting whatever
else but i we had a great vomiting
that's my reaction uh
our editor was so extraordinary leslie
jones i mean she's she's cuts i mean she
cut the thin red line she cut you know
paul thomas anderson's movie some of
them and and her father was an
extraordinary editor who cut films that
inspired us to make movies in the first
place um so we just had someone who from
the very beginning she was the only
person we met with
you know we couldn't believe that she
said yes
so she was there to guide us along the
way and that was a lovely lovely process
i i you know like honestly savored a lot
of the wisdom that i got from her and
some of the moments that we had cutting
the film yeah um i gotta go but are you
guys planning on doing another film
together and directing again
we don't have one right now we don't
have one right now i mean i i'll only
direct again with my buddy here uh i'll
only really directing i think with him
but uh but if if i'm not in the movie um
i i won't i won't be in every frame of
the movie again uh that that was not
exactly a fun experience
but uh maybe maybe if we find the right
if i find the right story that i feel
like but i'll always be in his movie
on that note thank you so much i really
hope it's a huge hit for you guys and
great talking with you both appreciate
you good to see you again man yeah later